Well
hello, how are you, Héctor Mejía greets you with
the briefing for today, Thursday
, March 4. The man accused of having
methamphetamine in his system when he
ran over and killed five cyclists
last December appeared in court
this morning touring for facing 14
charges  Due to this deadly crash that
happened on Highway 95 near
Searchlight, a judge declared that for being
admitted to having consumed nine times
over the allowed limit at the time of
this incident, today it will be decided if there is
enough evidence to go to trial
in other news more students
return  to classes today this time it will be the
turn of the group for students
from pre-kindergarten to third grade
Wednesdays of each week are dedicated to
a deep cleaning inside the
schools it is estimated that there are around
20 thousand students returning to
face-to-face classes today remember  to slow
down and respect the signs
in school zones
and little by little we are seeing that more
events return to las vegas'
the wifis beautiful popular festival
plans to return for september it is
outdoors tickets will be on sale
starting at 10 am today
however only a specific amount will be sold
due to the pandemic
the team  festival plans to reveal
information about the
security measures that will be in place during
the show closer to the
date and now we turn to the
weather forecast we will have sunny and clear skies
with temperatures hovering around
60 degrees for today we will reach 70
by tomorrow Friday and  then at the
weekend have a nice day I am héctor
mejía and this was your brief informative of
x de ao in Spanish
[Music]